in the last video we talked about the
central dogma and the first thing that
we're actually going to be talking about
is DNA replication so how what is DNA
replication like so there's this thing
called the measles install experiment
and medicine saw two scientists who
answered the question is DNA replication
conservative semi conservative or
dispersive so basically in short just to
kind of wrap things up you guys probably
already know this but they eventually
found out that DNA replication is
semiconservative how did they do that
that's what I want to talk about in this
video before we start talking about the
actual details of DNA replication so
they knew that DNA had nitrogenous bases
right the purines in the perimeter ins
so what they did was they took bacteria
e.coli and they grew it in dishes that
contained heavy nitrogen an isotope of
nitrogen so 15n so this is a heavy
isotope of nitrogen why did they do this
well that that seems like a really
peculiar thing to do the reason I did
this was so that if I mean the bacteria
needs nitrogen right so if they if they
grow in an environment which they only
hydrogen they have is the heavy isotope
of nitrogen that means any nitrogen that
they use will be that heavy nitrogen
anything that that any molecule in there
you in them that contains nitrogen or
that needs nitrogen will be made with
that heavy nitrogen okay so specifically
what did they care about
well they cared about the DNA right the
DNA contains these nitrogenous bases so
they want to make sure that all of the
DNA that's made initially has only the
heavy nitrogen so once they were
confident about that what they did was
it took they
transfer that ecoli those bacteria into
dishes that have light nitrogen or
regular nitrogen the more common isotope
so that's 14 n so basically what that
allowed for was that any newly
synthesized DNA would incorporate that
light nitrogen okay so what they did
then was they allowed the e.coli to
replicate for 20 and 40 minutes because
each replication cycle was 20 minutes
long and I'll explain later why they
actually had to have two replication
cycles in order to solidify the results
after they they allow the the equalizer
to replicate and track the replication
they centrifuge the samples afterwards
okay so they centrifuge after each
replication cycle so what were they
really testing well they had this theory
okay they thought well replication can
either be conservative semi conservative
loops semi conservative or dispersive
what are all of these things let's go
through this for a conservative
replication this is a imply that the
parent strands are concerned conserved
each time there's a replication cycle so
if the parent strand had nothing but
heavy nitrogen labeled in red then both
of these strands would stay together and
be the daughter strand while the newly
synthesized DNA would be completely
light nitrogen so this is the new newly
synthesized DNA and these are the
daughter strands of in conservative
replication so then in the second
replication these two strands would come
down here these would go here and then
there would be two new daughter strands
so this one and this one that was the
idea behind conservative replication
well what would occur in
semiconservative replication
semiconservative is the idea that one
strand is conserved and use the template
for the newly synthesized DNA so here in
the first daughter cell would get one of
these heavy nitrogen DNA strands and the
other daughter cell will get the other
and then the newly synthesized DNA what
would be one there and one there so this
is the new oops it looks look at em let
me change that newly synthesized DNA so
there would be the daughter each
daughter cell would have one parent
strand and one new daughter strand okay
and after a separate second replication
this would go to one cell that that
heavy strand and this one would go to
one cell and then we have this and this
as the new DNA okay seeing idea over
here that one strand from each goes to
the daughter cell whereas in
conservative both of the parents strands
went to one cell and then the new cell
had an entirely new DNA dispersed it was
the idea that any newly incorporated DNA
would be sporadic we incorporated into
the existing strands so here we're going
from completely red to half red and half
blue but the the newly synthesized DNA
is just incorporated it's like I said
sporadically and inside there and in the
second replication notice there's a
little bit more blue than there is red
because now there's more newly
synthesized DNA so this is what was
going on in theory they wanted to know
what what is it actually like which of
these ways is accurate so what they did
was they centrifuge their samples and
they got that they expected these
possibilities if replication was
conservative after the first generation
the first replication event what would
we expect well after the first
replication event there's one completely
heavy strand
and one completely light strand so there
would be uh you know if you're familiar
with a centrifuge centrifuges spin
things spin test tubes or tubes in
general so the heavier things go to the
bottom the lighter things stay up on top
so here we have this represents the one
light strand so this is the one light
strand and this represents the one heavy
strand okay and then after the second
replication event what they would have
expected was one heavy strand and three
completely light strands so what I've
drawn here is this is now like I've
drawn a light sort of density here this
is three light strands and this is one
heavy strand now this is what they would
have expected to see if DNA replication
was conservative so what as it turns out
neither of these things happen they
didn't see this and they did not see
this these things that not happen so
they knew that conservative replication
was definitely not it in the case of
semiconservative replication what they
would have expected to see is one band
in the middle I've drawn it in purple
because purple is kind of a hybrid
between blue and and red so why would
they have expected that well in the
first after the first replication event
each cell would be half old DNA half new
DNA half heavy half light have heavy
half light so they would only be one
band one band of of the two hybrid
strands okay oops
so this one band represents these
hybrids here half and half but half half
half light half heavy
what would they expect to see in the
second after the second replication
event after the second replication event
there would be half of the strands would
be half and half hybrids right this is
one one heavy one light one heavy one
light and then two two double strands or
completely light so that would expect to
see a light band and a hybrid band okay
so this is the hybrid band right says as
we have here so this is a hybrid band
and this here is the light band that's
what they would have expected to see for
semiconservative and I'll get to that in
just a second how they feel how they
discovered this was correct now notice
that for dispersive we would expect the
same thing that semiconservative after
the first replication event okay which
is just one hybrid band now why is that
well because in this case each band is
just half old DNA and half new DNA okay
so that would be expected to look the
same way as semiconservative after one
replication event so if they got this
right if they got this one hybrid band
they wouldn't know for sure if it was
semi conservative or dispersive which is
why they had to have a second
replication event which is why they did
that twice because after the second
replication event dispersive will just
have a lot more blue incorporated right
a lot more light nitrogen incorporated
in their DNA
so they're expected to see is that that
hybrid would move a little bit as this
purple is a little bit lighter it's a
little bit higher up so this is a little
bit lighter so
did see they saw this after the first
replication event right well if these
are the same so they saw both but after
the second replication event this is
what they saw they did not see this so
it is at that point that they concluded
that DNA replication is semiconservative
so that's sort of how the Mitchells
install experiment works hope that was
helpful one more thing I have a tutor so
if you live in Southern California feel
free to contact me via my local
University at gmail.com and if you want
more details check out the description
below
thank you for watching